[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم وتقبل الله صومكم اعرب البيت
الابيض عن ادانته الشديده لاستخدام الجيش
المصري العنف ضد المتظاهرين وقال ان مثل
هذا التصرف يعيد الديمقراطيه الى الوراء
ياتي هذا بينما تجري مسؤوله السياسه
الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي كاترين اشتون
لقاءات في القاهره بمختلف اطراف الازمه
المصريه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من
زاويتين ما هي المحددات التي حكمت المواقف
الدوليه بشان التطورات الاخيره في
مصر والى اي حد يمكن ان يسهم الدور
الخارجي في تحديد مسار الازمه
المصريه
الاكتفاء بنصف الادانه ونصف التاييد الذي
التزمت اغلبيه قوى المجتمع الدولي الفاعله
في عقاب عزل الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي يخلي
مكانه شيئا فشيئا لمواقف اكثر صراحه في
انتقاد سلوك الحكم الجديد في مصر خاصه بعد
احداث المنصه فجر السبت الماضي ففي اخر رد
فعل دولي على هذه الاحداث انتقدت بشده
واشنطن سلوك الجيش المصري تجاه المتظاهرين
بينما يقود الاوروبيون الذين سبق ان
اعربوا عن قلقهم من استخدام العنف ضد
المتظاهرين مساعي لتحقيق ما يسمونه عمليه
انتقاليه شامله تضم جميع الجماعات
السياسيه في مصر بما في ذلك الاخوان
المسلمون تتعاقب الايام منذ عزل الرئيس
محمد مرسي في الثالث من يوليو والشارع
السياسي المصري منقسم محتقن يتمسك فيه كل
فريق بمواقفه بينما تواصل احداث المنصه
فجر السبت تفاعل لها وجهود المصالحه تراوح
مكانها في ظل اتساع اله بين طرفي الازمه
جاءت زياره كاثرين اشتون مسؤوله السياسه
الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي لمصر بعنوانها
الطموح المتعلق بالسعي مع كل الوان الطيف
السياسي لبلوره نظام انتقالي شامل يضم
الجميع بمن فيهم جماعه الاخوان المسلمون
يجري نشاط اشتن ولقاءاتها المختلفه في مصر
على خلفيه دعوه الاتحاد الاوروبي لقيام
عمليه انتقاليه شامله تؤدي في اسرع وقت
ممكن لقيام نظام دستوري وانتخابات حره
وحكومه مدنيه وما فتئ الاتحاد الاوروبي
يهتم باحداث مصر الراهنه دان الاتحاد حادث
المنصه الذي قتل وجرح خلاله المئات من
مؤيد الرئيس المعزول فجر السبت ودعى جميع
القوى السياسيه لتجنب العنف وبناء جسور
الثقه بما يعين على تحقيق المصالحه احداث
المنصه تلك وجدت ادانه واسعه من مختلف
الاتجاهات البيت الابيض الامريكي دان
اعمال العنف بشده ووصفها بانها تعيد
الديمقراطيه للوراء وكان وزير الخارجيه
جون كيري قد طالب في وقت سابق السلطات
باجراء تحقيق مستقل وحيادي في تلك
الاحداث وفي ذات اطار رد الفعل الامريكي
على الاحداث الاخيره احجمت واشنطن عن نفي
او تاكيد ما ذكر عن رساله وجهها الرئيس
اوباما للرئيس المصري المؤقت ملتزما فيها
بمساعده المصريين على تحقيق الاهداف
الديمقراطيه وداعيا لتجنب العنف والتحريض
عليه من اجل بناء دوله تتمتع بمزيد من
القوه ودعى الامين العام للامم المتحده
السلطات المصريه المؤقته لتحمل المسؤوليه
في مبدا التعامل السلمي مع المتظاهرين
وضمان حمايتهم بغض النظر عن انتماءاتهم
وقال ان اي قتيل يسقط يصعب عمليه اخراج
البلاد من ازمتها الراهنه لكن الواقع ان
الشارع المصري لا يزال ملتهبا وتبقى
تداعيات ذلك مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات على
الاقل حتى اشعار اخر يفرزه الزخم
الدبلوماسي
الراهن
معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستديو السيد
وائل قنديل مدير تحرير صحيفه الشروق
المصريه والدكتور حسن نافع استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه القاهره ومعنا من لندن
الدكتور فواز جرجس مدير مركز دراسات الشرق
الاوسط بجامعه لندن اهلا بضيوفنا
جميعا لو بدانا بال الدكتور حسن نافع
برايك هذه المواقف الدوليه الان تجاه يجري
في مصر على اي اساس
تتم اولا على اساس المصالح كل دوله لها
رؤيه
لمصالحها داخل هذه الدوله التي تدور فيها
الاحداث طبعا الذي يحدد هذه المصالح هي
مؤسسات مختلفه وبالتالي قد يحدث نوع من
التباين بين رؤيه هذه المؤسسات لكن الذي
يحسم في النهايه القرار هو رئيس الدوله
لكن هناك ايضا تقييم هذه الدوله بمس مسها
باجهزه مخابراتها بوسائل اتصالاتها لما
يجري داخل الدوله موضوع الحدث اي لما يجري
في مصر الان كيف تقيمه وهل لديها رؤيه
صحيحه عما يجري بالضبط وعلاقه جيده مع كل
الاطراف ام لا هناك ايضا محددات دوليه
واقليميه لهذه الدوله للولايات المتحده
مثلا دول صديقه في
المنطقه كاسرائيل او دول اخرى عربيه
وبالتالي هي تتشاور معهم حتى تضبط مواقفها
مع هذه الدول وبالتالي اظن ان هذه
المحددات الثلاثه هي اهم المحددات في
تحديد
الموقف اذا كانت بهذا الشكل نسال سيد فواز
جرجس في في لندن هل تراها كذلك بهذه
الابعاد الثلاثيه سيد فواز جرجس سواء تعلق
الامر بواشنطن او باوروبا او
بغيرها في الواقع الحقيقه انا انا احاول
يعني الطريقه التي استطيع فيها ان افهم
الموقف
الدولي وخاصه الامريكي والغربي على
مستويين المستوى العام الاستراتيجي
والمستوى التكتيكي يعني يمكن تلخيص الموقف
الغربي بما فيه الولايات المتحده على انه
اعتراف ضمني بالواقع الجديد والنظام
الجديد الذي نتج عن ما حصل في مصر في
الاسبوعين الماضيين يعني هناك قناعه في
الدول الغربيه بما فيها الولايات المتحده
ان الرئيس المنزوع لن يعود وان اكثر ما
يمكن ان تقوم به السياسات الغربيه هو
الحقيقه دفع القياده الجديده على المضيه
قدما في عمليه الانتقال السياسي وعلى
اشراك كافه مقوت
واطياف العمل السياسي في بمصر بما فيها
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين انا اعتقد ان
العامل الاهم وهذه مصر نحن لا نتكلم عن
دوله يعني غير مهمه مصر دوله محوريه
العلاقه مع الجيش المصري مع مؤسسه الجيش
المصري علاقه عضويه علاقه استراتيجيه ا من
المستحيل وطبعا يعني من المستبعد ان تضحي
الولايات المتحده والدول الغربيه في هذه
العلاقه الاستراتيجيه مع المؤسسه هناك
قناعه معينه بان التحالف العضوي بين مؤسسه
الجيش والمعارضه بكافه اطيافها غير من
الواقع يعني على الارض ومن هنا هذه يعني
التردد
عدم الحقيقه الادانه وبشكل صريح لما تقوم
به المؤسسه الامنيه على الرغم انه البيط
الابيض اليوم ادان ما حدث في احداث المنصه
ولكن يعني اخذته حوالي عده ايام وهذا يدل
هذا التردد هذا الموقف الخجول يدل وبصراحه
على اهميه العلاقه الاستراتيجيه بين مصر
واهم مؤسسه في مصر مؤسسه الجيش والقياده
الامريكيه والمجتمعات الغربيه ولكن رغم هذ
هذه المصالح الذي التي اشار اليها الدكتور
حسن نافعه وهذا البعد الاستراتيجي
والتكتيكي الذي اشرت اليه الدكتور فواز
جرجس السيد هيثم
قنديل السيد وائل قنديل فيما يتعلق بهذه
المساعي او هذه الاتصالات هناك جمله ملفته
قالتها السيده اشتون بانها تجري ما تجريه
في القاهره بطلب من اصحاب المصلحه
الرئيسين بمعنى ان الاطراف السياسيه
الحاكمه قد تكون هي من طلبت تدخلا اوروبيا
في هذه الحاله هل هذا يغير من التحليل
الذي كنا نستمع اليه بالتاكيد يعني ال
العنصر الاهم في مجريات الامور في الفتره
القادمه هو مدى صمود هؤلاء المعتصمين
المعارضين لما جرى في 30 يونيو هذه هي
الورقه الاهم في المساله وهذه هي الورقه
التي تدفع الاتحاد الاوروبي او الولايات
المتحده الى اتخاذ مواقف او التعديل على
المواقف المتخذه ولكن يلاحظ من الاساس
وكلنا متفقون على ذل ذلك ان هناك موافقه
امريكيه ضمنيه على ما جرى في 30 يونيو حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يتحدث باراك اوباما عن ان
ما جرى هو
انقلاب يتجاهل تماما على كل اعفوا انفسهم
من عناء الرد على ولكن يعني كما قلت ان
العنصر الضغط هو حجم الاعتصامات التي باتت
تؤرق النظام الجديد في مصر وتؤرق ايضا او
تنقر على زجاج الضمير
العالمي حرك منظمات حقوقيه عالميه هذه
تمثل جماعات ضغط على القرار السياسي وعلى
الحكومات حتى لو
كانت المصلحه هي الغالبه في تحديد وبلوره
هذه المواقف ولكن ايضا المواقف الاخلاقيه
والضغط الاخلاقي على هذه النظم وعلى
دساتير هذه النظم وقوانين هذه النظم امام
شعوبها بالتاكيد ستثمر عن تبدل في
المواقف الرسميه مما جرى في 30 يونيو على
حسب معل معلوماتي ان زياره اشتن الى
القاهره اليوم تضمنت عرض بسته نقاط
اساسيه ولكن النظام الحاكم يرفض التزحزح
عن حدود 30 يونيو لان هذا هو الصيد الثمين
الذي بايديهم ولا يريدون ان يفرطوا به
والتفريط عنه او التنازل عنه لحظه واحده
سيفتح ابواب لتنازلات عديده و وعفوا على
ذكر هذه النقاط الست على كل سواء كان
الموقف الامريكي او الموقف الاوروبي او
الموقف الروسي لا احد اصلا يطالب بذلك
ولكن الكل وهنا الن الكل يؤكد على ضروره
الحوار الحوار الذي لا يستثني احد بما في
ذلك الاخوان المسلمين صحيح لان بديلا عن
الحوار لا يستطيع احد ان يستبعد شبح
السيناريو الجزائري او السيناريو السوري
ايضا بالنظر الى الممارسات التي جرت في
مصر خلال الساعات الماضيه او الايام
الماضيه فالامور مرشحه الى الاندفاع الى
سيناريوهات جزائريه او سوريه لان هناك نوع
من الانكار من جانب النظام الحاكم الى ان
ما يرتكب جرائم ه هذه النقطه التي تشير
اليها الان سيد دكتور حسن نافع ايضا
المشترك بين كل المواقف الدوليه ضروره وقف
العنف و وان كان
الامر يتجه الى ادانه ما قامت به السلطات
اكثر من الاشاره الى المعتصمين او
المتظاهرين كيف يمكن ان تتم هذه المعالجه
تمهيدا للحل السياسي يعني هناك مصلحه
دوليه عامه في ان تصبح مصر دوله مستقره في
جميع الاحوال ولا تتحول مصر الى دوله ا
يعني فاشله او دوله تسود فيها الفوضه هذا
يؤثر على المصالح ولن يحقق مصلحه احد على
الاطلاق ولكن هناك خلاف في الرؤيه
الاستراتيجيه حول ما
حدث دعنا نقول ان
الموقف الاوروبي مرتبط استراتيجيا بالموقف
الامريكي وبالتالي حتى ان حدث بعض التباين
في التفاصيل لكنه ا اكثر نشاطا اكثر نشاطا
وحتى لو حدث تباين في بعض التفاصيل الا
انه مرتبط استراتيجيا بالموقف الامريكي
موقف روسيا مختلف وكان مرحبا على الفور
بالتغيير الذي حدث في مصر لاسباب
استراتيجيه تتعلق ايضا بما يدور في
المنطقه وخاصه في بالنسبه للوضع السوري
لكن انا اظن ان هناك مصلحه دوليه لجميع
راف بما فيها روسيا ان تعالج المساله
سياسيا ولا تتحول الى ما يشبه الحرب
الاهليه ومن هنا حرص كاترين اشتون على ان
تاتي مره اخرى وربما تزور الدكتور مرسي
ولا استبعد ان تقوم بنوع من من الوساطه في
هذا الامر ان استطاعت ان تزور الدكتور
مرسي وان تفتح معه حوارا هذا ليس بالامر
المستبعد ولكن في النهايه الكل يدرك انه
اذا لم تتم تسويه بالوسائل السلميه و
تشارك جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في اداره
الفتره القادمه المرحله الانتقاليه
القادمه فسوف يعني يحدث اضطراب في مصر سوف
يكون له تاثير كبير جدا وخطير جدا على
الوضع في المنطقه وبالتالي على الوضع في
العالم هل عنصر الوقت هنا مهم جدا الكتور
فواد جرجس لان الكل يتحدث عن ضروره التوصل
في اسرع وقت ممكن اذا اخذنا تعبيره السيده
اشتون في اسرع وقت ممكن الى انتخ حره
تشكيل حكومه بقياده مدنيه العوده الى
النظام الدستوري هل هناك شعور بضروره
الاسراع حتى لا تفلت الامور ان صح
التعبير مما لا شك فيه ان عامل الوقت مهم
للغايه واذا اذا تمعنا جيدا في تصريح وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي قال ان مصر وصلت الى في
لحظه فارقه تحدث عن اهميه معالجه الاح
احداث الداميه الدمويه في مصر ومن هنا
الحقيقه انا اعتقد هناك تنسيق بين الاداره
الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي وان يعني
الدبلوماسيه المكوكيه التي اعتقد ان كثرين
اشتون سوف تقوم فيها هي جزء لا يتجزا من
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه والاوروبيه
لمحاوله الحقيقه نزع فتيل الازمه في مصر
احد يعني هناك قناعه اما كانت في واشنطن
حيث اجلس هنا انا بلندن او بباريس انه لا
يمكن استبعاد جماعه الاخوان المسلمين انه
لا يمكن القفز فوق هذه الحاله الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه ليس لانهم الحقيقه مغرمون
بجماعه الاخوان المسلمين كما بعض عناصر
المعارضه تقول في في مصر لان جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين واقع سياسي لا يمكن
القبس فوقه والخوف في العواصم الغربيه ان
اي محاوله لاستبعاد جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين ضرب هذه الجماعه العوده الى يعني
عقرب الساعه الى 2000 بعد 2000 بعد 2011
سوف يؤدي الى حاله عدم استقرار وحاله ليس
فقط حاله على النموذج الجزائري حاله عوده
الى التسعينات في مصر 1992 الى 1997 حاله
عدم استقرار اللي بسموها اللو انتني ورفير
ويمكن ان تؤذي ليس فقط اللا استقرار في
مصر يكون لها تداعيات على المنطقه ككل ومن
هنا محاوله معالجه الازمه وبسرعه من خلال
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي ممثله
بكاترين اشتون نعم على كل بعد الفاصل
سنتطرق الى التاثير المحتمل للدور الخارجي
في ازمه مصر يعني في النهايه كل هذه
المساعي وكل هذا الاهتمام الى اين يفترض
ان ان يقود في مستقبل الايام لنا عوده بعد
قليل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الدور الذي يمكن
ان يلعبه المجتمع الدولي في تحديد مسار
الازمه في مصر سيد وائل قنديل في النهايه
كل هذه التحركات اين يفترض ان تقود في
النهايه في النهايه يعني كل ما ما يبذل من
جهد الان يحاول ان يوقف الاندفاع الى
شلالات دماء وسيناريوهات كما ذكرت جزائريه
او سوريه ولكن في في المحصله الذي سيحسم
الموقف هو الوضع الداخلي ثوره 25 20 يناير
الذي حسما هو الموقف في الداخل الجبهه
الداخليه ومدى صمود الذين خرجوا في هذه
التظاهرات هم الذين غيروا في موقف المجتمع
الدولي الذي جاء لاحقا للاراده المصريه
التي تجلت في الميادين والتحق بها المجتمع
الدولي ما يجري الان واستمرار هذا
الاعتصام وانضمام فئات جديده الى هذا
الاعتصام يعني اليوم مثلا هناك مجموعه
تسمى وراكم بالتقرير هي مجموعه من شباب
الثوره كانوا اعتقد تقرير لجنه تقص
الحقائق في جرائم ثوره 25 يناير اصدروا
اليوم تقريرا مهما للغايه يرد على كلام
وزير الداخليه في قوله ان الشرطه لم
تستخدم ابدا رصاصا ضد المتظاهرين هناك
استنهاض للضمير الثوري المصري لكي يرى ما
يجري على الارض رغم كل محاولات التعتيم
الاعلامي وكان الاحداث التي تدور في مصر
تدور في غرفه مظلمه لا يتصور النظام مثلا
انها ستصل الى الميديا العالميه وان هناك
من من وسائل الاتصال الحديثه ما ينقل
المجازر التي تمت وتتم في في مناطق مختلفه
الى الراي العام العالمي الذي هو بالضروره
سيكون رد فعل لمدى الصمود الشعبي المصري
ولكن مع اهميه هذا العامل على الارض في
الميدان دكتور حسن نافع من الصعب ان نتخيل
ان واشنطن او الاتحاد الاوروبي سيظل ينظر
الى اين ستتجه الرياح حتى يحدد في النهايه
كيف سيتصرف لا هو لا ينتظر
ليعرف الى اين تتجه الرياح هو يحاول تقييم
ما يجري على الارض ويحسب موازين القوى وقد
ينجح في حسابها بدقه وقد لا ينجح لكن في
نهايه المطاف انا فهمت سؤالك على يعني على
اساس الى اي مدى يمكن ان يؤثر الطرف
الخارجي على مواقف الاطراف المحليه نفسها
و واحيانا نرتكب اخطاء جسيمه جدا كنا نقول
مثلا ان الولايات المتحده لها علاقه
متميزه جدا بالجيش المصري وتقدم معونه 1.3
من مليار دولار سنويا
وبت القيادات العسكريه تدربت في الولايات
المتحده وبالتالي لا يمكن الا ان يكون
للولايات المتحده يعني راي حاسم وقد
تستطيع ان تؤثر بشكل مباشر على موقف تبين
ان هذا ليس صحيحا وانه عندما يتعلق الامر
بالامن الوطني المصري
ف يعني يستطيع الجيش المصري ان يقول لا
وبحسم للولايات المتحده الامريكيه نفس
الشيء بالنسبه للعلاقه مع جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين كان هناك تصور ان الولايات
المتحده بنت علاقه مهمه واستراتيجيه مع
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين لكن من منظور معين
ان جماعه الاخوان المسلمين هي الاقدر على
تحقيق الاستقرار السياسي في مصر لكن عندما
تبين ان هناك معارضه شرسه لجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين وانها غير قادره على تحقيق هذا
الاستقرار السياسي وانه يمكن ان ينشا
اوضاع عدم استقرار بسبب حتى حكم جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين يمكن للولايات المتحده
ان تغير مواقفها لكن الى اي مدى وباي
ادوات وباي وسائل تستطيع الولايات المتحده
ان تاثر مباشره على الاخوان لتغيير موقفهم
مثلا حتى يتزحزح في انتهاء في في اتجاه
التسويه السلميه هذا امر يصعب التكهن به
هناك من يتحدث عن لوبي للاخوان المسلمين
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وانه
مازال قويا هل هذا صحيح ا لا ادري بالضبط
لكن من المؤكد ان هناك لوبي لكن هذا
اللوبي لن يكون قادرا على التاثير في وضع
تغير يعني تغير تغيرت بعد تغير موازين
القوى على الارض واكتشاف الولايات المتحده
ان جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ليست بالضروره
بهذه القوه قد تكون جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين اداه لعرقله التسويه لكنها ليست
بالضروره اداه لفرد الوضع بشكل حاسم في
هذا المشهد الملتبس ولو انه من الطريف ان
نعرف ان هناك لوبي لطرف مه الولايات
المتحده على الاقل حتى وان كان للاخوان
المسلمين دكتور فواز جرجس في ظل هذه
المعطيات كيف يمكن للطرف الخارجي ان ان
يصبح مؤثر في تحديد مسار الازمه دون ان
يتورط او يقع في نفس الاخطاء التي وقع
فيها عندما حاول ان يتابع الثوره ضد
مبارك في الواقع الحقيقه هذه النقطه مهمه
للغايه لان اداره بارك اوبا باما لا تريد
التورط في الازمه المصريه يعني يحاولون ان
لا يكون هم القصه اي تورط امريكي بنظر
الاداره الامريكيه يمكن ان يعقد الامور
ولا يعني يحل الوضع المعقد ولكنني اريد
تجديد على نقطه يعني سريعه نظريه انا
اعتقد انه من الاهميه بمكان عدم المبالغه
والتفريط في المبالغه بالدور الخارجي لان
هذه احد الاطروحات التي نحن بالعالم
العربي انه ما تريده الولايات المتحده
يحصل هذا ليس صحيح والاحداث في السنتين
الاخيرتين يعني كانت واضحه للغايه انا
اعتقد ان ما تريده الولايات المتحده هو
استقرار سياسي في مصر تريد يعني ان تجد
حلا سلميا للوضع اشراك كل القوى السياسيه
ولكنها لا تريد ان تط تتورط شخصيا مباشره
في الصراع في في مصر والنقطه الاخيره
الحقيقه ان نحنا انا اعتقد ليس فقط العامل
الداخلي والاهم بالطبع حاله الحراك
السياسي الغ الغليان السياسي والعلاقه
الان المباشره بين المؤسسه الجيش وقوى
المعارضه المصريه انا اعتقد اننا نغفل
عاملا مهما وهو العامل الاقليمي ان هناك
تواصل تواصل مباشر بين القيادات الغربيه
ودول الخليج انا اتكلم بصراحه العامل
الاقليمي عامل مهم جدا لان العامل
الاقليمي يؤثر ليس فقط على عدم قدره
الولايات المتحده ان تستخدم قضيه
المساعدات العسكريه للجيش لان العامل
الاقليمي اصبح عاملا مباشرا في تغيير
الواقع الاقتصادي والمادي على الارض ومن
هنا انا اعتقد ان ما سوف نشهده في الايام
والاسابيع القادمه هو محاوله متواضعه من
قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي من اجل سد الفجوه
العميقه بين حركه الاخوان المسلمين
والنظام الجديد في مصر وانا اعتقد الحقيقه
ان حركه الاخوان المسلمين في وضع صعب
ومعقد للغايه معقد للغايه لانها الحقيقه
وصلت الى طريق مسدود وهي تواجه الان ليس
فقط يعني المؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه تواجه
علاقه مباشره بين المؤسسه العسكريه ومن
هنا هذا الوضع الجديد غير المعطيات في
الدول الغربيه لان هناك قناعه بدات تتشكل
في واشنطن والعواصم الاوروبيه ان جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين ليس لديها القدره لديها
القدره على عرقله تسويه سياسيه وانتقال
سياسي و لكنها لم تعد تستطيع يعني التاثير
وبطريقه جوهريه رئيسيه في الوضع السياسي
المصري وخاصه عمليه الانتقال السياسي نعم
اذا في نهايه البرنامج نفس السؤال للسيد
قنديل والدكتور نافع في النهايه
الاوروبيون او الامريكيون لن يفرضوا شيئا
على مصر صحيح يعني كما لم يفرضوا شيئا في
ثوره 25 يناير ودعني اقول لك ان الموقف
الامريكي والموقف الاوروبي الرسمي ليس
سعيدا للغايه بثورات الربيع العربي بدليل
ان انه لا يريد ان ينطق بكلمه انقلاب على
وصف ما جرى في مصر في 30 يونيو رغم انه
بالاساس جاء لتفريغ ثوره 25 يناير من
محتواها واعاده المعادله على الارض الى ما
كانت عليه في زمن حسني مبارك ولكن دون
وجود حسني مبارك ولا نستطيع ان نغفل هنا
هذا هذه البهجه الاسرائيليه بما جرى بعد
30 يناير نعم دكتور نافع 30 يونيو الاطراف
الخارجيه سواء دوليه او اقليميه لا تستطيع
ان تفرض على الاطراف المحليه تصورا ما
للتعامل مع الازمه ولكن هناك اداره رشيده
او اداره غير رشيده وبالتالي الاداره
الرشيده من جانب طرف او الاداره غير
الرشيده من طرف اخر هي التي ستؤثر على
مسار الازمه وهذه الاداره يجب ان تاخذ في
اعتبارها المواقف الاقليميه وال الدوليه
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور حسن نافع استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه القاهره شك شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من لندن الدكتور فواز جرجس
مدير مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط بجامعه
لندن وشكرا ايضا للسيد وائل قنديل مدير
تحرير صحيفه الشروق المصريه بهذا مشاهدينا
الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه